if you've ever been online and if you
haven't I don't know what you're doing
watching this video you know that many
websites are tracking and studying your
behavior and in a way to help you by
presenting products and information that
they think that they believe based upon
your browsing history and other
characteristics are going to be of great
interest to you but there's also a
darker side to that activity while that
may add great convenience to you the
truth is that that also permits them to
look at questions like what do they
estimate you're willing to pay for that
product now a lot of people think
mistakenly that you're supposed to
charge the same price for a product to
everybody that's not the case you can't
discriminate based on certain criteria
race religion sexual preference but it's
perfectly fine for me to charge this guy
more than that guy because I think he'll
pay more and just look at airplane
tickets as a perfect example of that
sort of thing now here's the problem
we're taking those kinds of decisions in
these websites and Amazon itself is a
fantastic example of this and we're
incorporating very sophisticated machine
learning algorithms they're designed to
manage the overall behavior of the group
of people who are visiting that website
in order to optimize profitability for
the companies that are running those
websites and they will cut you the least
slice of pie the smallest slice of pie
that they can to get you to incent you
to do what they want you to do hi in
order to maximize the profits for the
corporation now you may have been on
Amazon and you may go put things in I
use this what's the call to save for
later or something in your cart and you
come back the next day and good news you
know this book is 3 cents less or that's
2 cents more this is a dollar more like
there were people doing that this is a
machine learning algorithm and what it's
doing is analyzing the time of day and
the characteristics of what you bought
in the past and how you've responded
different kinds of incentives and where
you came from and what kind of browser
you're using is a major factor of
anything you can in order to adjust the
price to just the point
where you're gonna buy at the highest
possible price you as an individual have
freedom of choice it's free country you
buy it you cannot buy it that's great
but we as a group a set of customers
purchasing from Amazon or some other
site we adhere to certain statistical
properties so as a group we don't have
that that freedom because it can be
managed by the entity on the other side
whenever there's a information asymmetry
like that they know what you are likely
to buy by what your characteristics are
and they can optimize the yield on site
based upon that they're at an advantage
over you Amazon is a wonderful company
but it is basically one giant machine
learning algorithm that is designed to
do what's called arbitrage it knows what
it can buy things for and knows what it
can sell things for and it can adjust
the profitability in that zone order
maximize sales in order maximize profits
and it can do so in a way that is far
more efficient than has ever been
possible in retailing before so when I
think of Amazon the fact that they're
selling goods is incidental I think of
it like stock trading programs buy low
sell high buy here so there there's a
there's a spread these really are
arbitrage systems and you are the
mechanism by which to these companies
maximize their profits
you
[Music]